a small but spirited hardcore of navalny
supporters braving -20
outside this police station as inside a
hastily convened court ruled on
extending alexey navalny's detention for
another 30
days i've seen justice made a mockery of
a lot
but apparently the old man in the bunker
is so afraid of everything
they just tore up all the criminal
procedure laws and threw them in the
trash
who works for navalny's anti-corruption
foundation vanished one night a year ago
the next thing his colleagues knew he
was in the russian arctic
on forced military service
i'm afraid that what i want to say to
the government for this year in the
arctic
is not translatable to your beautiful
language to be honest i lost a year of
my life
i couldn't do anything politically or
personally
but because of this stolen year i became
angrier and i'll work harder to destroy
this power
[Music]
and that is what navalny is calling for
for people to take to the streets
international calls for his release came
in thick and fast
the foreign secretary dominic raab
saying rather than persecuting mr
navalny
russia should explain how a chemical
weapon came to be used on russian soil
and the police station seemed as good a
spot as any to ask russia's foreign
minister just that
the germans have said that they've given
you the
blood and tissue and material clothing
samples that you would need
to carry out a proper criminal
investigation
so i'm not entirely clear what would be
holding you back
i don't know where you're getting the
information that germany passed us the
samples
it's not true and the answer we got from
german authorities three days ago when
they prepared for the january 17th
return of navalny
says further down that there is only the
facts they received from the valny and
his wife yulia
but the organization for the prohibition
of chemical weapons does have those
samples
given them by the germans and russia is
a member
ultimately what happens to alexei
navalny will be
a political decision and it is very
clear that the kremlin
do not want him around
navalny has already suffered so much at
the hands of the russian authorities
but he has always had the strength and
the determination
to carry on
[Applause]
dynamagne sky news moscow